herzlich willkommen ich hoffe sie wissen
worauf sie sich heute ein lassen
georg wilhelm friedrich hegel war einer
der einflussreichsten aber eben auch
einer der schwer verständlichen
philosophen überhaupt bald feiert er
seinen 250
geburtstag und falls ihr unschlüssig
sind ob sie mitfeiern sollen oder nicht
in der folgenden stunde erfahren sie
alles was sie über hegel wissen müssen
von der dialektik bis zum absoluten
geist erklären wird uns das alles die
berliner philosophen und ekel experten
die neben uns herzlich willkommen
ja mit hegel haben sie sich vermutlich
grad den schwierigsten philosophen
überhaupt haus gesucht warum denn zu
hegel gekommen bin ich eigentlich vor
allem über fragen also gar nicht wann
ich dachte das ist der größte und
schwierigste philosophen mit dem werde
ich mich auseinandersetzen sondern eher
weil ich mich mit verschiedenen fragen
beschäftigt habe vor allem mit fragen
welche rolle spielen eigentlich
erfahrung wie können wir eigentlich aus
der wirklichkeit etwas lernen und da
habe ich durchaus mit verschiedenen
philosophen beschäftigt und bin dann
besonders auf hegel gestoßen wobei die
ganze zeit mich immer schon fasziniert
hat ich habe mich davor auch mit kant
beschäftigt und denke auch dass die
ganze zeit in faszinierende zeit ist
weil in dieser zeit viel die menschen
viel neues über neue selbstverständnis
nachdenken und ich würde sagen dass das
bis heute auch für uns relevant ist und
da gehört natürlich dann also die zeit
um 1800 russische revolution 17 89 man
erkannt haben sie schon erwähnt usw
was würden sie denn sagen bei heek das
ist so die die wichtigste einzig die wir
diesen denker verdanken
ich will vielleicht mal eine wichtige
einsicht von hegel nennen
und das ist die einsicht dass es eine
art von kritik gibt in der wir in der in
kritisieren etwas an der position
bewahren die wir kritisieren und dass
dieser art von kritik
auch oft die quelle unserer eigenen
ansichten und überzeugungen ist also bei
sehr vielen überzeugungen die wir so
haben wenn wir uns überlegen woher wir
die haben dann sind sie aus einer
kritischen auseinandersetzung mit
anderen entstanden und diese prozesse
sind deswegen auch für uns sehr wichtig
und das würde ich sagen ist eine sehr
wichtige einsicht von hegel das ist
diese art von kritik gibt also dann
kritisiert etwas aber man lernt es nicht
gänzlich ab sondern nimmt das beste
draus mit und macht etwas neues oder was
wäre der mann versucht eben in der
kritisierten position nachzuforschen was
eigentlich dasjenige ist was an ihr
bewahrenswert assist und mit dem
arbeitet man dann selber das bestimmt
man dann gemäß auch der eigenen vorgaben
so kommt es dazu dass man letztlich
modifizierte veränderte positionen
erreicht und hegel verbindet das mit
einer menge anderer thesen nämlich zum
beispiel damit dass die ganze geschichte
ein solcher ablauf von irgendwie immer
neuen konkretisierungen von vergangenen
positionen ist aber ich finde diese
grundidee dies auf jeden fall sehr
bemerkenswert das ist nämlich diese art
der kritik gibt und dass die auch für
unser verständnis und philosophie sehr
entscheidend ist weil es zum beispiel
heißt dass philosophie auch irgendwie
immer ein stück weit dialogisch ist
auseinandersetzung mit anderen
positionen ist und eben auch
geschichtlich ist wie groß war deren
einfluss auf die geschichte der
philosophie sie unterrichten yasim
professorin an der freien universität in
berlin für geschichte der philosophie
migros einfluss auf die denker nach hin
insgesamt würde ich denken dass er einen
sehr großen einfluss hatte
einerseits konkret auf viele denker
zu nennen wären zum beispiel gab marx
sicherlich dann auch noch viele bis ins
zwanzigste jahrhundert und auf der
anderen seite ist hegel der denker des
geschichtlichen also auch so radikal zu
sagen dass eben kunst und philosophie
und all diese disziplin geschichtlich
betrachtet werden müssen das heißt dass
sie immer in der zeit verhaftet sind
auch dass er in der zeit verhaftet sind
und dass auch die entwicklungen mit
zudem gehören was die kunst ausmacht
also wenn sie jetzt auch ein kunstwerk
betrachten dann ist eben dieses
kunstwerk nicht nur zeitlos sondern es
trägt die geschichte in sich und um das
kunstwerk zu verstehen gilt es auch
diese geschichte mit im blick zu haben
und ich denke dass dieser gedanke für
das neunzehnte jahrhundert ganz
entscheidend gewesen ist dann bis zum
historismus und bis zu der frage ob
dadurch nicht alles relativ wird ist zu
den fragen inwiefern wir ein ende der
geschichte kennen aber das denke ich was
das neunzehnte jahrhundert eher
ausschlaggebend und das geht schon auf
hegel auch zurück und henkel war der
erste der das wirklich so prominent
gesagt hat dass als geschichtliches
zeitlich ist ja also in dieser
konsequenz das ist tatsächlich eine
entwicklung gibt und das ist dass man
sich mit der entwicklung
auseinandersetzen muss um etwas zu
verstehen und das ist auch so etwas gibt
wie eine logik der geschichte ja in dem
sinne walde er hat ja gesagt die
philosophie ist ihre zeit in gedanken
gefasst das heißt eine beschäftigung mit
der eigenen zeit immer genau also für
die philosophie ist dass auch
ausschlaggebend und das ist auch
wirklich mit vielen anderen sachen
verbunden eine interessante these dass
auch heißt dass wir zwar die zeiten
stückweit transzendieren können indem
wir eben denken was zu dieser zeit
stattfindet dass wir aber auch immer von
derzeit abhängig sind und das heißt auch
das hegel von seiner zeit abhängig ist
und dass wenn wir philosophieren wir uns
letztlich immer erst mal richten auf die
konkreten realisierungen die wir
vorfinden sei es im politischen oder
einen anderen verhältnissen und diese
dann analysieren das heißt auch dass die
philosophie zwar einfluss nehmen kann
aber ihr einfluss bei hegel ist
eigentlich ein sehr indirekt weil ich
analysiere eigentlich das gegeben und
auf diese weise werden quasi dann auch
wieder ressourcen freigelegt ist ja auch
eine art von vielleicht kritischer
auseinandersetzung mit dem was es gibt
und aus diesen analysen können dann
wieder impulse für neue dinge entstehen
aber es ist nicht so dass man die quasi
direkt ändert durch philosophie sondern
er
über analyse hegels einfluss war ja
nicht nur groß auf die philosophie
geschichte sondern auch die gesellschaft
das ganze bis bis heute gibt es da
spuren von heckel und er war ein großer
denker der freiheit
mich würde interessieren was er jetzt in
zeiten der pandemie gesagt hätte zu
diesem look dazu diesen
freiheitseinschränkende maßnahmen gegen
die die leute auf die straße gegangen
sind ja also ich würde schon sagen dass
man sagen kann das hegel ein philosoph
der freiheit ist dann muss man natürlich
sich im konkreten angucken wie er diese
freiheit idee entwickelt werden wir
vielleicht später noch mal dorf zu
sprechen kommen aber denke dass für
hegel ist einerseits sehr wichtig ist
auch in der politischen philosophie die
freiheit des individuums zu waren also
der ganze zweck des staates liegt darin
die freiheiten der individuen zu
bewahren insofern könnte man jetzt sagen
wäre er sicherlich nicht ein freund von
einschränkungen und würde dieser
einschränkung auch sicherlich nur
akzeptieren sofern sie wirklich nötig
sind
es gibt dann aber so einen zweiten punkt
bei hegel nämlich dass diese
individuellen freiheiten letztlich nur
realisiert werden können und auch
letztlich nur bestand haben wenn sie
eingebettet sind in einem system oder in
ein staat der das allgemeinwohl im blick
hat also der zweck des staates ist auch
das allgemeinwohl und dieses zu bewahren
weil das eine bedingung für den erhalt
der individuellen freiheiten sind also
da ist ebenso eine verschachtelung
dieser themen bei hg das ist schon
interessanter so dass ich schon denken
würde dass man wenn man jetzt die
einschränkung in diesem sinne als
unterstützung
das allgemeinwohl sieht für das die
individuellen bürger dann auch letztlich
eintreten müssen weil es auch in ihrem
eigenen individuellen weg liegt dass man
dann wiederum einschränkungen auch schon
akzeptieren kann
da zeigt sich schon eine wichtige
einsicht nämlich das alles für hegel
teil eines größeren ganzen essen dachte
individuelle freiheit ist nur wirklich
eigentlich in einem staat wo alle
anderen r freiheit genießen dieses
gemeinwohl drais und so weiter ja genau
also nicht nur dass es in einem ganzen
ist sondern es zeigt sich schon auch
immer zu dieser idee von hegel
dass man gucken muss dass das eine durch
etwas anderes möglich ist und das was es
ist auch nur durch etwas ist selbst wenn
das andere ersten vielleicht sogar
gegensätzlich aussehen mag also
allgemeinwohl und individuelles
interesse scheinen einander gegenüber
gestellt zu sein aber wenn man genau
hinguckt und ist das allgemeinwohl und
ja der erhalt des allgemeinwohls
tatsächlich eine bedingung dafür dass
die individuellen interessen dauerhaft
durchgesetzt werden können das ist dann
ich glaube da ist schon was dran und das
ist schon mal sehr typisch finden auch
heikel war ja ein gewisser weise ein
kind seiner zeit da war keine ausnahme
17 70 geboren in stuttgart 27
august und es waren vor allem zwei dinge
die ihnen stark geprägt haben sein sein
denken nämlich einerseits die die
gedanken von immanuel kant dem großen
deutschen aufklärungs philosophen und
andererseits das ereignis das epochale
ereignis der französischen revolution
gleich mögen sie erläutern erstmal die
revolution was sind das für auswirkungen
hat er als das der henkel was ist mit
ihm gemacht
ja also tatsächlich werde ich auch sagen
dass kaum etwas so großen eindruck auf
sie gemacht hat wie die französische
revolution
ich habe ja schon gesagt dass ich denke
man kann ihn auch als wieder sucht der
freiheit lesen und das wird in der
russischen revolution ja auch
ausgedrückt man könnte vielleicht sogar
sagen oder hegel hätte vielleicht sogar
gesagt dass die prinzipien freiheit
gleichheit brüderlichkeit sich irgendwie
in seiner philosophie wiederfinden wenn
man eben die das prinzip der freiheit
hat dieses aber nur verwirklicht werden
kann wenn wir uns gleichberechtigt an
erkennen und diese gleichberechtigte
anerkennung wiederum nur bestand haben
kann wenn sie im allgemeinwohl also in
der brüderlichkeit in dem sinne
aufgehoben ist also dass diese
prinzipien durchaus prinzipien der
hegelschen philosophie geworden sind
aber neben der begeisterung hat
sicherlich auch die angst vor rück also
vor der jakobiner herrschaft das von
vielen und auch von hegel
das denken geprägt und ich denke dass da
auch mit blick auf einige sachen wir
jetzt überlegung zum widerstandsrecht
oder so auch schon gesehen werden muss
dass
dass er auch angst hatte dass das ganze
im chaos enden könnte und das ist
sicherlich auch so dass er davon
seinerzeit abhängig ist und von den
eindrücken die dann die
schreckensherrschaft durchaus auch auf
die menschen gehabt hat ich habe gelesen
hat eine ungeheure faszination auch von
der person von napoleon ja das würde ich
sagen das hängt vielleicht auch ein
stück weit damit zusammen dass napoleon
der kommt dann fast wenn man das was
nach ethischen perspektive liest kommt
das fast so vor als wäre er eben die das
individuum was diese verschiedenen
prinzipien wieder in eine einheit bringt
und wirtschaft diese ganzen
errungenschaften wieder friedlicher
weise zu lösen aber trotzdem
beizubehalten und wir würden das
wahrscheinlich heute in vielen punkten
anders sagen aber ich denke dass da
tatsächlich die schreckensherrschaft und
diese sachen im hintergrund nur große
rolle gespielt haben er hat ihn sogar
gesehen in jena auf dem pferd reitend
und schreibt dann in irgendeiner stelle
also die weltseele zu pferd oder den
weltgeist sind ja die geschichte
vorantreibt
es sind so die sachen die ich jetzt gar
nicht so hervorheben würde ich ja das
ist tatsächlich so dass hegel irgendwie
davon sehr beeindruckt werden aber in
seiner wieder so viel denken spielt
letztlich eine rolle dass er versucht
diese gegensätzlichen bestimmungen die
er sieht auch politischer absieht dass
er versucht die durch eine bestimmte
starts konzeption zu lösen und seine
seine theoretischen einsichten die
förderung der vielen auch immanuel kant
oder er übernimmt viel verkannt und
gewinn aber auch über ihn als vielleicht
mögen sie kurz erläutern was ist das
tatsächlich auch eine sehr komplexe ich
würde denken dass hegel in sehr sehr
vielen punkten von kant ausgeht was in
der zeit auch oft gemacht worden ist
nämlich was übernimmt ja und dann diese
sachen aber in einer bestimmten weise
modifiziert und gründet man ist da auch
ein bisschen wieder dass kritik modell
kleine ausschlaggebend ich denke dass er
zum beispiel mit kannte these durchaus
teilt das freiheit das prinzip der
theoretischen und der also den fragen
des wissens und der fragen des
uns ist das ist auch kant hätte gesagt
dass seine philosophie eine philosophie
der freiheit ist und nicht nur der
freiheit im sinne von dass es freiheit
gibt sondern dass wir uns auch bewusst
sind dass wir frei gewesen sind also
auch da denke ich folgt er erkannt und
zwar nicht nur in fragen der handlungen
sondern tatsächlich auch in fragen der
erkenntnis was weniger
selbstverständlich ist also wir müssen
uns auch erkennen
eben als spontane freie wesen selber
verstehen nur so ist erkenntnis möglich
was heißt das ist etwas wo er kann folgt
das heißt jetzt bei beiden dann etwas
unterschiedliches bekannt heißt es
tatsächlich dass die begriffe die wir
haben
die die wirklichkeit so wie wir uns auf
sie beziehen auch strukturieren dass wir
diese begriffe als objekte in die welt
auch hereinbringen
darin liegt die spontaneität des objekts
bekannt das heißt wir formen wir
strukturieren die welt indem wir sie
wahrnehmen erkennen denken durch unsere
kategorien und begriffe genau und das
hat dann was sehr auch subjektives
wenngleich transporte darin besteht zu
sagen das bedeutet überhaupt nicht dass
nicht objektive erkenntnis möglich ist
weil wenn wir uns jetzt hier auf
gegenstände zum beispiel auf diesen
tisch beziehen würden dann würden wir
diese gegenstände anhand von prinzipien
konstituieren diese prinzipien sind aber
von uns geteilte die auch die stabilität
unserer wirklichkeit ausmachen und die
auch überhaupt schon zugrunde liegen
wenn wir uns in der form auf objekte im
unterschied zu anderen objekten oder so
beziehen
da sind ja keine materie haufen für uns
sondern es sind tatsächlich gegenstände
mit eigenschaften die in casal
beziehungen stehen und so weiter und
diese strukturierung mit casall bzw
die machen zwar letztlich wir aber wir
machen das in einer weise dass wir uns
trotzdem auf die gegenstände mit
objektiven erkenntnissen beziehen können
hegel folgt kann irgendwie in dieser
grundidee das ist prinzipien gibt die
dinge strukturieren und die auch in
unserem denken liegen
aber das was ich jetzt gerne bei kant
beschrieben habe das würde jeder als
jetzt im unterm strich zu subjektiv
ansehen weil dann hat man immer so das
gefühl irgendwie machen wir die welt
und dieser logischen prinzipien sind
letztlich eher sowas wie reine gedanken
prinzipien die nicht die wirklichkeit
strukturieren und die frage stellt sich
ja tatsächlich wieder sogar noch immer
wie schaffen wir es überhaupt etwas
wahres über die wirklichkeit zu sagen
aber das ist die grundfrage die da beide
verfolgen kann gibt er diese subjektive
antwort und hegel versucht an dieser
antwort anzusetzen aber zu zeigen dass
es trotzdem nicht in der weise subjektiv
ist diese logischen prinzipien die
strukturieren nachher die wirklichkeit
unabhängig von uns ist also unabhängig
von uns ist dann auch wieder was muss
man darüber nachdenken weil wir
eingebunden sind in dieser logischen
prinzipien und insofern sind wir auch
immer teil dieser prinzipien aber es ist
nicht so dass diese prinzipien irgendwie
subjektive durch uns nur in die welt
kommen
bevor wir da noch tiefer einsteigen in
die theorie würde mich interessieren was
war eigentlich für ein mensch die hat
der gerät also am bemerkenswertesten
weil hier finde ich dass er mit
schelling und hölderlin und einigen
anderen im tübinger stift war und dort
seine grundausbildung auch in
philosophie bekommen hat das mit 20
jahren da habe ich war das ziemlich
genau und das ist aber auch deshalb sehr
bemerkenswert weil ich denke das was man
auf jeden fall hegel als mensch zu
sprechen muss ist dass er irgendwie an
freundschaften sehr interessiert war und
auch sowas hat wie also ich glaube dass
ja auch ein ganz guter freund war und
dass man sozusagen und das bin ich das
ist was was man auch in seiner
philosophie irgendwie vielleicht sogar
merken kann auf jeden fall hier sind
diese themen von anerkennung und auch
gleichberechtigte anerkennung schon so
dass ich denken würde ein stück weit ist
das auch etwas was ihn in seinem leben
wichtig gewesen ist also das wäre jetzt
auf jeden fall was soll ich sagen würde
das ist etwas was man bei seinem leben
heraus heben kann
ansonsten denke ich dass er jetzt
eigentlich so im vergleich also wenn man
seine bücher liest dann sind die
wirklich zutiefst beeindruckend als
mensch habe ich den eindruck dass er
relativ normal
natürlich jetzt auch auf den beruflichen
erfolg schließlich in berlin
rektor der universität es war schon ein
unglaublich großer erfolg dann und auch
für ihn sicherlich persönlich wichtig
aber das sind halt alles vielleicht er
mit seiner philosophie gar nicht so in
später dann in in berlin und 20er jahren
genau wo er seine rechtsphilosophie
schreibt davor war auch mal in bern
hauslehrer habe ich gelesen hat da in
den sommerferien viel viel viel gelesen
feeling punkt zu bekommen und er ist ein
denker der irgendwie immer aufs ganze
geht und eine theorie des welt ganze
nennt werkzeugen wie was in den menschen
geht um die natur um das recht und moral
und religion und kunst und alles und
alles hängt irgendwie miteinander
zusammen und dafür ist eine die ganz
wichtig nämlich die idee der dialektik
und um diese komplizierte idee zu
erläutern haben wir eine pflanze
mitgebracht das in tomaten einen tomaten
gurken und vielleicht mögen sie seine
grundidee dass alles ein prozess ist ein
dialektischer prozess kurz erläutern
anhand von pflanzen ja also die idee der
dialektik ich denke dass dialektik
eigentlich für hegel
also was ist wie das prinzip einer
bestimmten bewegung in der eine
einheitliche bewegung stattfindet oder
eine bewegung von einer einheit die sich
in einer bestimmten weise entwickelt und
er selber bietet dafür die an so nimmt
dafür gerne bilder aus der botanik und
vieles davon kann man sich auch auf
diese weise tatsächlich ganz gut
veranschaulichen ist übrigens von goethe
beeinflusst also bitte bei goethe findet
sich ja zu dieser idee der mutter
botanik irgendwie vieles was man der
fruchtbar machen kann
jetzt wenn man von einer pflanze ausgeht
dann würde man den samen ja als ausgangs
bilden der die genossen des kleinen
samen
eigentlich ja auch schon drin angelegt
ist genau das würde auf jeden fall auch
jetzt mit zu hegels grundidee gehören in
diesen samen ist angelegt was mach ja
die ganze entwicklung ausmacht und in
der entwicklung gibt es verschiedene
phasen und diese phasen kann man in
verschiedener hinsicht voneinander
unterscheiden und allem sind sie
irgendwie strukturiert durch
ausdifferenzierung und wieder
zurücknehmen in einer einheit ist auch
so eine idee die sich bei goethe auch
stattfindet er nennt das ausdehnung und
zusammenziehung und das ist ja so im
bild hätte man den samen das yanar
einheit da hat man noch das gefühl dass
alles zusammen und aus diesen samen
entsteht der stängel und dann die
blätter und das ist ja schon mal
vielfalt und auch eine vielfalt bei der
man durchaus sagen würde in gewisser
weise kommen die blätter jetzt sogar in
ein konkurrenzverhältnis zueinander und
bekommen eine eigenständigkeit dieser
idee der einheit der pflanze irgendwie
sogar ein stück weit entgegen steht also
auf diese rechnung nicht um die um dass
die ressource wasser und lee gelang so
gut genau wann können wir jetzt eben
auch chemischen sind schon fast anfangen
von der negation zu sprechen ja die
negieren sich in gewisser weise
gegenseite und ok diese blätter wird
jetzt auch bei dassow stellt aber auch
goethe das da werden jetzt letztlich
zurückgenommen in den stängel der dann
wiederum die die ausgang für die blüte
ist also dass der stempel
den haben wir dann als einheit und die
blüte wieder als eine vielfalt in der
jetzt wieder dasselbe entsteht ist jetzt
schon differenzierter also in kleineren
gebündelter kommt aber wieder zu
vielfalt und diese vielfalt wird wieder
zurückgenommen in die frucht als einheit
also da hätte man diese phasen die man
in dieser bewegung irgendwie geltend
machen kann
gleichzeitig hat man für hegel soll das
auch eine veranschaulichung einer
bestimmten form von selbstbezüglichkeit
sein weil sie jetzt eben in der frucht
ja dann wieder den samen haben also im
ende ist der anfang wieder genau
angelegt oder teil eines größeren ganzen
genau dies ist teil eines größeren
ganzen ist jetzt auch kann man jetzt
auch ein stück weit noch mit der pflanze
mit gehen also mit dem bild der pflanze
mitgehen wenn man sagen kann das ist
eine selbstbezüglichkeit aber jetzt
eigentlich eine in der nicht mehr nur
die individuelle pflanzen rolle spielt
weil die individuelle vergeht ja mit dem
samen der hat und was wieder entsteht
ist eine neue individuelle pflanze was
erhält sich also in diesem
widerständigen vergehen und in die einer
zurücknehmen ist behält sich letztlich
das allgemeine nämlich dann in dem sinne
die art der pflanzen die dort lässt sich
genau durch die verschiedenen individuen
so dass man auch dann wieder so ein
prozess geltend machen kann indem
negation und einheit rolle spielt bei
henkel kommt da immer dieser begriff der
aufhebung denken wir mehrdeutig ist also
etwas wird aufgehoben heißt einerseits
kann das heißen es wird negiert
vernichtet andererseits kann aufhebung
heißen es wird bewahrt man eben etwas
auf und drittens die bedeutung es wird
emporgehoben ihr nächstes stufen ja
genau der ist genauso ganz bewusst
gewählt denke ich und der soll diese
verschiedenen aspekte die sie genannt
haben eben tatsächlich alle bewahren das
ist in diesem prozess das was irgendwie
vorsichtig
im prinzip ist das ja erst mal auch
wirkt das jetzt so als würde man sagen
ja das ist ja so was wie eine
beschreibung von prozessen der wir so
durchaus auch etwas abgewinnen können
hegel nimmt aber dieses eben als
tatsächlich ein prozess von dem er der
meinung ist dass der strukturiert und
für die wirklichkeit ist bei dem man
auch eben immer also einer notwendigkeit
der entwicklung sprechen kann also dass
sich diese sache so entfaltet und dann
wieder in der einheit zusammen genommen
wird sondern eben etwas sein wo die das
ist quasi wie so ein gesetz was
tatsächlich die sachen strukturiert die
bewegung und diese bewegungen sollen
eigentlich überall vorliegen also für
die die menschheitsgeschichte
weltgeschichte ebenso wie für
denkprozesse und diese übereinstimmung
soll sich wiederum auch begründen lassen
weil wir ja in dieser welt geschichte
oder auch in der natur eingebunden sind
wir sind auch natürliche wesen und
wir entwickeln unsere denkprozesse
natürlich auch in diesem zusammenhang
und erkenntnis heißt letztlich auch sich
diese ganzen zusammenhänge zu
vergegenwärtigen und so kommen wir dann
ja auch dazu die dialektische methode
als eine logische methode haben zu
können weil wir diese prozesse letztlich
analysieren und ablesen also die
wirklichkeit ist in diesem dialektischen
wandel drin also muss uns dass unser
denken eines die wirklichkeit erfassten
wir legen wir auch dieses jahr
durchlaufen
genau in gewisser weise sind wir also
entsteht unser denken in diesen
prozessen und bei unserem denken ist das
besondere dass es diese prozesse auch
noch denken nachvollziehen kann
das heißt die selbstbezüglichkeit die
wir jetzt bei der pflanze eben gesehen
haben die ist beim menschen oder beim
geistigen wesen eine die nachvollzogen
werden kann die nicht nur einfach
stattfindet sondern die in diesen
stattfinden auch nach tatsächlich sich
selbst transparenz ist und darin liegt
sicherlich für hegel auch was ganz
entscheidendes in geistigen das ist das
gegenwärtig halten kann also ich zum
beispiel kann als individuum ein dass
meine gattung also im ein mensch sein
das ist was mich ausmacht aber was uns
auch verbindet und was auch dazu führt
dass bestimmte sachen stattfinden können
das kann ich halt auch erfassen das ist
bei der individuellen pflanze eben nicht
so und insofern ist die der vernichtung
preisgegeben
während das ein mensch im fall der
menschen ebenso ist dass dieses
bewahrende tatsächlich etwas ist was für
das individuum auch transparent ist und
darin liegt dann ebenso ein ganz
entscheidender unterschied
aber wie gesagt ich würde mal sagen also
dass das wirklich hart über hegel ist
dass er das nicht als nur irgendwie
bieten als einfach beschreibung
möglichkeiten ansieht als solche sind
sie nämlich wirklich oft sehr fruchtbar
auch in politischen das hat sich denke
ich auch gezeigt und man kann sich damit
auch wirklich sehr viel irgendwie
deutlich machen gerade in
zwischenmenschlichen und sei aber für
jede sind es wirklich strukturieren die
prinzipien der realität selbst ja und er
führt das ganze ja vor in seinem buch
ein buch phänomenologie des geistes das
erscheint 1806 und es
das dürfte das lesen im studium leider
wenig verstanden wahrscheinlich die
meisten bei der ersten lektüre aber
steckt unglaublich viel drin
wie würden sie einem kind erklären worum
es da geht also sie waren mit dem kind
muss ich noch mal gucken ob wir nicht
noch mal also die grundidee der
phänologie des geistes denke ich macht
tegel in der einleitung klar und die
würde ich noch mal so formulieren dass
es eigentlich um die frage geht was ist
erkenntnis ist eine frage die man auch
von anderen philosophen kennt die von
kant aber sagen wir mal einfach für das
kind von anderen philosophen kind und
jetzt materie von anfang an auf eine
problematik aufmerksam die einem beim
beantworten dieser frage begegnen soll
nämlich um die frage zu beantworten was
erkenntnis ist müsste ich die frage
eigentlich schon immer beantwortet haben
weil ich ja kriterium brauche wie ich
die frage beantwortet was erkenntnis ist
also wenn ich jetzt eine antwort darauf
geben
woher weiß ich dass das die richtige
antwort ist dafür müsste eigentlich die
antwort die ich gegeben habe
irgendwie schon vorliegen das müsste
schon klar sein dass das die richtige
ist also ich brauche ich suche den
maßstab für erkenntnis aber um den zu
finden brauche ich das doch schon das
ist so ein bisschen dieses szenario was
hegel in der einleitung irgendwie
entwickeln möchte und aus diesem dilemma
soll die technologie des geistes uns
raus führen und zwar indem sie den weg
eine entwicklung anhand anderer position
oder anhand anderer vorschläge wählt ich
sage also nicht einfach als philosophin
sodass es erkenntnis weges meinung dass
zum beispiel kant gemacht hat hier sind
die kategorien und das sind die
notwendigen bedingungen und so weiter
sondern ich betrachte andere mögliche
vorschläge dazu was erkenntnis ist und
kritisiere die im hinblick darauf was an
den defizitär ist und was an den
bewahrenswert ist und das ergebnis
dieses ganzen prozess ist soll dann
hegels eigene philosophie darstellen und
und der den weg darzustellen das ist es
und er fängt dabei ganz einfachen dann
nämlich wenn ich jetzt dieses klassische
einfach dir eine sinnliche gewissheit
dass jetzt ich hier zum beispiel eine
fahrweise oder einen geschmack habe und
so weiter wenn ich das trinke und
ausgehend von dem zeigte dass man da
nicht stehen bleiben kann sondern dass
man irgendwie das ganze komplexer ist
und das pikante eben schon gesagt hat
dieses glas mehr ist als nur
sinneseindrücke sondern strukturiere
dass es ist hat es sein ding mit
eigenschaften selbst das ist dann aber
nur eine position er muss wieder darüber
hinaus gehen und so weiter ja ganz genau
wie die aussagen also auch dass man
anfängt quasi mit positionen die jetzt
durchaus noch nichtmals gigantische
wären sondern so was wie eben ganz
einfache sinnliche gewissheit das wird
dann so weiterentwickelt dass immer
klarer wird dass müssen logische
prinzipien angenommen werden die das
strukturieren sind dann wird es aber
auch erweitert zu sozialen phänomenen
und so weiter weil das für hegel alles
zu der frage gehört was erkenntnis das
ist ja super interessant erkenntnis ist
kein individueller prozess sondern ein
kollektiver sozialamt es dass er geht
dann selbst das bewusstsein oder das
selbstbewusstsein hängt davon ab dass es
irgendwie andere wesen geht die
bewusstsein oder selbstbewusstsein haben
und da ist ein ganz wichtiges kapitel in
diesem buch das so genannte herr knecht
kapitel asyl herrschaft und knechtschaft
was auch für karl marx ganz ganz wichtig
und vielleicht mögen sie da kurz
erläutern was was da die einsichten
hebel sind also zunächst mal würde ich
schon sagen dass man dieses kapitel so
wie es in der phänologie auftritt auch
tatsächlich als schritt auf dem weg der
beantwortung der frage was erkenntnis
ist ansehen kann
zur erkenntnis gehört nämlich dass ich
mich als freies individuum erkenne
dazu gehört dass es andere individuen
gibt die ich als meinesgleichen erkennen
obwohl wir auch gleichzeitig
unterschiede haben das gehört zur
kenntnis und selbsterkenntnis station
ist auch tatsächlich eine bedingung
dafür dass ich so eine ganz einfache
aussage machen kann wie irgendwie das
was da durchsichtig also dass dieses
glas hier voll wasser ist dann ja und
das wäre jetzt tatsächlich in dem
beispiel auch so ich brauche sie als
potenziellen bestätige meiner aussage
also eine dritte person perspektive
deswegen ist der andere wichtig aber ich
brauche sie auch weil es klar sein muss
dass ich nicht da an diesen dingen
allein eine eigenschaft zu sprechen
schreibe sondern dass das zu schreiben
von eigenschaften was ist was irgendwie
gemeinsam stattfindet das andere machen
was auch mehreren gegenständen zusammen
wird ist also ziemlich komplexe
angelegenheit wo der andere andere
denkende wesen tatsächlich schon mit
vorkommnissen damit es überhaupt
erfolgreich stattfindet und was hat das
jetzt aus mit herrenknecht ja und ja
also erst mal hat das mit herrenknecht
zu tun in also deswegen glaube ich kommt
dass an dieser stelle vor weil hier
sagen will dass das nur funktioniert
wenn es eine wirkliche selbsterkenntnis
gibt und die wirkliche selbsterkenntnis
ist nur möglich wenn ich von jemand
anderem auch also anerkannt werde wie
ich bin also was ich gerade bei dem glas
gesagt habe dass ich ihre bestätigung
brauche
das gilt eben auch für meine
selbsterkenntnis ich kann mich nicht
alleine erkennen sondern ich brauche
auch da jemanden der mich als das
anerkennt als was ich mich selbst
erkennen also insofern ist das
tatsächlich kann man das erstmal alles
noch unter dieser perspektive anführen
für hegel was eigentlich erkenntnis ist
gleichzeitig finde ich aber auch völlig
legitim und auch fruchtbar
das kapitel jetzt nicht nur in diesem
kontext zu sehen sondern man kann auch
sagen dass da im kern ebenso eine
anerkennung theorie die jetzt einfach
praktisch relevant ist und sozial
philosophisch relevant ist dass die da
drin steht und das ist die perspektive
die jetzt wie marx auch er angenommen
hat also dass eben dieser
anerkennungsprozess die hegel da
beschreibt so sind dass man sagt man
braucht für das eigene selbstverständnis
die anerkennung als freies wesen und das
kann nur unter gleichberechtigten
stattfinden nicht wenn asymmetrische
verhältnisse bestehen also dass auf
jeden fall eine demenz und das andere
was in dem kapitel eine große rolle
spielt ist inwiefern unser bezug auf den
gegenstand auch verschieden bestimmt ist
und da spielt die arbeit eine besonders
große rolle weil der knecht derjenige
ist der tatsächlich arbeitet daher
genießt januar also den anderen
gegenstands bezug und auch dieser aspekt
ist jetzt mit blick auf marx besonders
wichtig der grund und hegel werte da die
arbeit auf oder ab wann sitzt du hast
was der knecht macht ja auf also es wird
so dass man sagen kann
herr und knecht beziehen sich auf
einander aber das findet keine echte
anerkennung statt weil der herr den
knecht nicht als seinesgleichen
anerkennt und der knecht
auch im asymmetrischen verhältnis zum
herrn steht aber gleichzeitig auch vom
herrn nicht die anerkennung bekommt er
haben möchte aber der knecht also sind
aber auch miteinander vermitteln durch
die produkte oder durch diese länder
oder der herr ist genauso abhängig und
knecht hegel will das jetzt eben
umdrehen daher ist sogar abhängiger von
knecht ja weil der herr halt zum
beispiel seine gegenstände ja nur über
den knecht bezieht der genießt genießen
ist zwar erst mal ein schöner zustand
ist aber einmal wo man an der produktion
der sache eben nicht beteiligt sind und
dadurch auch bestimmte formen von
irgendwie der eigenen produktivität
nicht erfahren kann während der knecht
in seiner arbeit sein selbstbild quasi
irgendwie komplexer ausbildet indem er
sich als produktiv erfährt indem er eben
seine freiheit anhand dieses gegenstands
irgendwie wird ihm seine freiheit
dadurch in einer anderen weise fast
sicher
das heißt in diesem prozess herr knecht
ist der knecht er derjenige die an
bestimmten positiven bildungsprozess
durchmacht und dann auch zu einer
größeren selbstständigkeit in diesem
sinne kommt als der herr es ist ist da
schon angelegt was bei vox sahen
entfremdung heißt diese idee dass wir in
unseren produkten uns nicht mehr
wiedererkennen
genau aber die in fremden würde man
jetzt noch sagen das ist tatsächlich
wenn irgendwie die lebensprozesse einer
gesellschaft insgesamt so sind dass
diese produktionswege immer länger
werden und wir immer weniger direkten
bezug zu ihren mit dem haben was
hergestellt wird das ist jetzt in der
phänologie des geistes durchaus auch
thema aber jetzt nicht so primär in dem
kapitel
er knickt also dieses inter subjektive
haben sie schon gesagt es ist ganz
zentral ist es zwischenmenschliche und
nicht nur für die arbeit sondern auch
für die für das thema liebe und da gibt
es diese schöne formel von von hegel
dass wir im anderen bei uns selbst sind
vielleicht mögen sie das noch erläutern
was für ein bild von liebe hegel einig
geprägt hat und wie das mit diesem im
anderen bei sich selbst sein zusammen
also ich glaube entscheiden bei hegel
ist dass es verschiedene verhältnisse zu
meinen mitmenschen gibt und diese
verschiedenen verhältnisse auch alle
vorkommen müssen oder alle dazu gehören
es gibt liebesverhältnisses rechtliche
verhältnisse
und es gibt schließlich auch
verhältnisse wo man sagen würde man ist
in den staat eingebunden und das sind
durchaus verschiedene verhältnisse also
es gehört quasi auch mit zu unserer zu
unserem differenzierten dasein dazu dass
wir uns in diesen verschiedenen
beziehungen befinden
es bleibt das ist ganz wichtig für das
was er ausführen möchte und und trotzdem
könnte man mit blick auf auch die das
verhältnis der auch das rechtliche
verhältnis sagen dass wir beim andern
bei uns selbst sind in dem sinne als
dass das uns verbindende jahr das
menschsein ist und wir wissen dass wir
eben beide mensch sind dass wir dieses
wissen auch haben und das dann auch
unsere geben zum beispiel brüderlichkeit
ausmacht und in der liebesbeziehung ist
diese beziehung für hege leben in der
viel unmittelbaren grund weise gegeben
und wird auch ein bisschen anders
ausgeführt als jetzt bieten rechtlichen
verhältnissen aber wir brauchen den
anderen immer für dieses gemeinsame
selbstverständnis und irgendwie ist die
dialektik nochmals spürbar man verliert
sich vielleicht im anderen man geht auf
in dem moniert dann auch andererseits
dialektisch gedacht erst ganz sich
selbst durch den anderen in der liebe
oder ist das zu einfach gedacht ich
würde gar nicht unbedingt sagen so
einfach aber ich glaube das hängt jetzt
also heckels grundidee auch bei der
dialektik und bei dieser einheit cd wir
jetzt schon manchmal hatten ist ja das
ideal quasi also jetzt mit dem hübschen
sind aber das was wir eigentlich haben
wollen ist einheit aber gleichzeitig
akzeptanz der differenzen
das heißt sowohl eine liebesbeziehung
vor allem aber auch eine
rechtsbeziehungen in unterschiedlicher
weise die bestehen gerade darin dass ich
den anderen in seiner andersheit
vollkommen anerkennen kann also der ist
wirklich anders er hat ganz andere
vorstellungen und so weiter gleichzeitig
ist der andere aber meinesgleichen ist
er mit mir irgendwie dasselbe wir sind
nämlich menschen das macht uns aus und
diese sachen irgendwie beide
gleichermaßen im blick zu haben das ist
gerade das was jetzt irgendwie die
beziehungen irgendwie den beziehungen
ihren wert gibt und dass andere wäre ja
so ein modell wo man sich ganz verliert
und erst durch den anderen also dann
wirklich eine einheit mit dem anderen
herstellt das ist in der liebe mehr so
als in rechtlichen verhältnissen und
sicherlich auch gar nicht wunsch und ich
würde sagen das regelt das als
grundprinzip auf jeden fall auch in
liebesbeziehungen jedenfalls für den
späteren heben ist
sie haben sich die sozialen verhältnisse
angesprochen das reicht ihnen verschafft
die die familie die die moral und diese
dinge sittlichkeit und das läuft bei
henkel alles unter dem begriff geist und
zwar objektiver geist warum nennt er das
geist und was versteht darunter geist
also gegen unterscheidet ja natur und
geist und dann bei gais subjektiven
objektiven und absoluten geist und das
ist jetzt tatsächlich das was eigentlich
die gesamte wirklichkeit ausmachen
sollen also natur subjektiven objektiver
und absoluter geist und ich würde denken
dass hegel mit geist erst mal meint dass
es da ein prinzip gibt was nochmal
anderes vergegenwärtigen kann und
dadurch auch jetzt zeitlich gesprochen
sondern von gleichzeitigkeit stattfinden
kann also es können prozesse stattfinden
und diese prozesse können eben zugleich
gedacht werden und dadurch ist jetzt in
der in der struktur auch immer eine
andere art von selbstbezüglichkeit noch
mal möglich so ein bisschen so wie wir
es eben im ausgang von der pflanze
gesagt haben dass finden eben nicht nur
prozesse statt sondern diese prozesse
können auch gedacht werden und dadurch
in einer bestimmten form auch kann etwas
bewahrt werden was sonst innerhalb
diesen prozessen immer verloren zu gehen
scheint zum beispiel so was wie eben
jetzt eben das menschsein kann gedacht
werden und in diesem sinne auch vom
individuum als das zu bewahrende erfasst
werden
das ist also das geistige und den
subjektiven geist das würde jetzt erst
mal das sein was jetzt mein
anthropologische dieser ausstattung
anbetrifft der objektive geologie
vielleicht genau psychologie
anthropologie der objektive geist wären
alles die sozialen rechtlichen
verhältnisse und der absolute geist ist
so eine art von selbst thematisierung
des geistes wo eben jetzt kunst religion
und philosophie für hegel hingehören das
reflexionsvermögen vielleicht genau also
genau also als ein
hat von irgendwie selbstverständigung
formen unterschiedlicher art mit denen
also so wie das am anfang mit dem mit
der kritik und derzeit noch mal gesagt
wurde also die philosophie betrachtet ja
durchaus bestehende verhältnisse aber
transzendiert diese indem sie eben denkt
was da eigentlich strukturen
verwirklicht sind und das passiert in
anderer weise auch in kunst und religion
und dadurch verständigt das geistige
wesen sich auch immer über sich selbst
also der mensch dann eben in diesen form
und die haben zu allen zeiten
stattgefunden und entsprechend haben die
eben dann auch selber immer diese
geschichtlichkeit geht das wort
zeitgeist als ein viertel zurück ich
glaube ich nicht dass das nur zeitgeist
aber das trifft dass das was er meint
auch dass so etwas wie zeitgeist gibt
das ding in der luft liegen also dessen
mussten weil sie jetzt nicht genau so
könnten gut im 19 jahrhundert entstanden
sein da gibt es ja eine menge solcher
wörter die da entstehen dann auch
irgendwie interessant auch so was wie
alltäglichkeit und so in welchem maße
soll so ein vokabular zu dieser zeit
irgendwie tatsächlich auch auftritt was
auch wirklich damit zu tun hat dass die
menschen zeitlichkeit irgendwie und ihr
verhältnis dazu sehr stark reflektieren
und das findet sich auf jeden fall auch
bei hegel also da ist er auch wie er
selber sagt kind seiner zeit und das und
auch in vielen punkten seiner
philosophie vor
hegel war ja wenn jetzt diese soziale
nochmal anschauen eigentlich ein
befürworter eines starken staates starke
institutionen auch tradition
gewohnheiten und so wie verhält sich das
dann nicht so zu seiner idee von
freiheit weiteren freiheitsdenker ist
dennoch irgendwie jetzt stark dafür
plädiert für starke rollenbilder
institutionen starken staat wie passt
das zusammen
also das geht wieder auf diese grundidee
zurück dass die individuelle freiheit
eigentlich das ist was zu bewahren ist
wenn man aber sich jetzt wenn man das
würde für hegel in der sphäre der
bürgerlichen gesellschaft politisch
gesehen so seien in die bürgerliche
gesellschaft ist die also ist die sphäre
in der mann tatsächlich die
individuellen freiheiten verfolgt
das führt aber zu widersprüchen so
hägele jetzt kommt wieder diese idee
dass da eine negation vorkommt weil ich
das mal mit menschen dann auch streitig
machen
es führt ganz konkret auch zu
verhältnissen von armut und es führt
auch dazu dass die individuen nicht mehr
den anderen als ihresgleichen anerkennen
und auch dadurch ein schlechtes selbst
verhältnis bekommen also hegel macht da
durchaus auch gewisse psychologische
beobachtungen dass man eben dadurch auch
den wert seines eigenen lebens irgendwie
nicht mehr so klar vor augen hat und
grundthese und das ist die stelle an der
max daneben letztlich widersprechen
würde ist dass man dem entgegenwirken
kann dieser selbstzerstörerischen
tendenz in dem der staat und die
institutionen da einspringen also es
gibt innerhalb hegels durchaus lösungen
dafür indem der staat dann zum beispiel
gewinnen bestimmte einschränkungen
vornimmt und vor allem auch in dem die
institutionen zwischen diesen
allgemeingut was vielleicht sehr
irgendwie erst mal in unserem sinne
abstrakt wirkt und meinem individuellen
leben in dem ich mich in den
institutionen auch verwirklichen kann
meine rollen da auch habe ich bin halt
dann auch nicht nur individuelle bürger
sondern ich bin auch staatsdiener und
dadurch habe ich selber schon so eine
vermittlung einer individuellen freiheit
mit dem allgemeinwohl und das ist der
weg den hegel politisch gesehen wäre
deswegen würde er jetzt wieder sagen der
ist zwar ein gewisser gegensatz schon
richtig was sie sagen zwischen meinen
individuellen freiheiten und diesem
allgemeinwohl aber dieser gegensatz kann
einem durchaus fruchtbaren sinne
aufgehoben werden aber das klingt schon
konservativer das läuft auf einen
gewissen konservatismus china wurde
heraus staatsphilosophie tituliert des
politischen obrigkeitsstaat dass der
dann nach den sparbeschlüssen auch mit
mit sensoren mit mit überwachung und so
weiter operierte in seinem spätwerk in
der rechtsphilosophie kommt das schon
zum vorschein und da gibt's dann sätze
wie was vernünftig ist das ist wirklich
und alles oder und was wirklich ist das
ist vernünftig als er rechtfertigt da
irgendwie auf den status quo
ja das ist richtig obwohl ich noch
einmal unterscheiden würde zwischen
äußerungen von hegel wo er sich
tatsächlich einfach auch in einer
bestimmten weise als konservativ dann
gezeigt hat und dem was jetzt
tatsächlich an grundidee in seiner
politischen philosophie liegt was
vielleicht jetzt auch durchaus jetzt zum
beispiel im vergleich zum markt als
konservativ angesehen werden kann
was aber meines erachtens mit dem
anderen jetzt nicht identisch ist also
hier gehabt dann den preußischen staat
irgendwie auch als ein staat behandelt
indem die freiheit realisiert ist ich
denke das hätte er von seiner
philosophie aus in der frauen überhaupt
nicht machen müssen und so auch mit
blick auf andere sachen
während dieses dass die wirklichkeit
veränderst richter um sich selbst zu
schützen
ich denke also philosophisch finde ich
immer die frage interessant inwiefern
muss er das überhaupt tun oder inwiefern
tut er das weil er zum beispiel
bestimmte ängste hat sei es um sich
selbst zu schützen sei es auch weil er
meint dass in seiner zeit doch ein
starker staat irgendwie wichtig ist weil
irgendwie da kommt jetzt wieder dieses
thema das irgendwie denkt vielleicht
ruft das sonst aus und das endet alles
im chaos und so es sind auch
interessante frage wieso verständigt vor
allem interessant sich zu fragen liegt
das jetzt quasi in seiner grundidee und
anlage oder sind das auch sachen dir
anders hätte ausführen können und da
muss man halt immer unterscheiden ich
denke diese idee das was wirklich ist es
vernünftig die liegt schon tief in der
grundüberzeugung hegels das ist jetzt
keine ängstlichkeit oder keine in dem
sinne oberflächlicher konservatismus
sondern die liegt schon daran dass er
denkt diese struktur der entwicklung die
wir eben beschrieben haben und es um die
dialektik ging die führt schon dazu dass
letztlich sich die sachen die sich
realisieren immer in diesem sinne
irgendwie immer komplexer aber auch und
differenzierter mehr differenzierung zu
lassen aber gleichzeitig die einheit
bewahrt wird und in dem sinne dann
vernünftig sind okay aber das heißt wenn
dieser welt prozess jetzt ein prozess
hin zu immer mehr freiheit und vernunft
dann ist dieses vernunft sich im
speziellen sind gemeint war es gibt ja
kriege katastrophen usw
da würden wir nicht sagen hey
rechtfertigt das alles endlich etwas
geschieht das ist vernünftig sondern
weil er meint das irgendwie anders
ja also ich meine er sagt ja immer dass
der dass der fortschritt in dem in dem
bewusstsein der freiheit liegt also wenn
man jetzt hier gefangen würden was ist
jetzt wirklich der fortschritt dann
müsste er natürlich nicht pauschal sagen
alles ist besser geworden
es gab nie eine verschlechterung oder so
sondern dann würde das schon heißen dass
die menschen im laufe der geschichte
immer mehr verstanden haben was freiheit
ist und die ihre verhältnisse immer mehr
so ausgerichtet haben dass diese
freiheit auch von allen realisiert
werden kann
das ist die grundidee dieser fortschritt
idee von hegel ich meine karl marx würde
vielleicht auch noch so was sie kann so
ganz anderen schlüssen zu einer
klassenlosen gesellschaft hier also kein
max freund glaube ich der these hegels
das geschichte als fortschritt im
bewusstsein der freiheit ist worin lag
es tatsächlich widerspricht ist dass es
eine harmonisierung möglichkeit von
bürgerlicher gesellschaft und staat gibt
ja also ich meine skipping große also es
ist strittig ob das jetzt nicht auch ein
start noch weiter fortsetzen wollte aber
der wäre auf jeden fall nicht so dass er
diese bürgerliche gesellschaft bestehen
lassen
sarah hecken ist ja ein befürworter
einer monarchie sogar mord monarchie ja
das würde genau das gehört jetzt wieder
zu den sachen wo ich denke das ist
vielleicht in der grundstruktur der
politischen systeme die entwirft gar
nicht unbedingt angenommen es kommt
darauf an dass dieses gesamte politische
system durch einen repräsentanten
ausgezeichnet ist weil der eben dieses
prinzip der einheit noch mal
veranschaulicht das ist jetzt bei ihm
der monarch und auch noch durch erbe
entschieden einem monat aus überlegung
wäre dann auch das könnte aber auch
jemand anders sein es braucht aber
innerhalb dieser idee die er hat
eigentlich nur jemanden der dieses
system auch in einer person
irgendwie repräsentiert ja also dass das
würde ich denken ist jetzt noch nicht so
das system dem demokratischen
grundprinzipien tvi widersprechen würde
kommen wir gegen ende noch zu diesem
ausgehend vom objektiven geist von den
sozialen verhältnissen zu diesen
absoluten geist sie haben gesagt kunst
religion philosophie gehören dazu das
ist für hegel auch seine stufen ab
also irgendwie überwindet die religion
auch die kunst erhebt sie auf warum sie
da diese hierarchie also tatsächlich
sieht er die man kann dann irgendwie
sich überlegen inwiefern das heißt dass
die kunst tatsächlich ihre rolle ganz
verloren hat ihre aussagekräftige das
würde sicherlich zu weit gehen
also warum er sie sieht es weil er denkt
das ist immer eine art von
selbstverständigung des menschen gibt in
der ganzen geschichte gab
selbstverständigung das heißt was was
bedeutet mensch sein wie ist die
wirklichkeit in das voerder arbeitet man
im kunst in religion genau also genau
alles was wir eben jetzt vorüber wir
auch gesprochen haben auch über welche
entwicklung haben wir wie sind die
politischen verhältnisse was ist mein
selbstverständnis was ist eigentlich
gerechtigkeit und so weiter das wird
alles vergegenwärtigt nochmal nachdem es
realisiertes vergegenwärtigt in formen
der kunst der religion und der philosoph
ganz besonders natürlich inwiefern sind
wir frei das würde auch immerhin der
kunst demontiert und vor allem religion
versteht hier vor allem als ein bewusst
werden von freiheit was ja schon so eine
bewusst werden von freiheit da ist sie
also zu sich selbst kommen ähnlich wie
mit einem spiegel kann man vielleicht
sagen diesen absoluten geist also es
gibt irgendwie man plötzlich bestimmte
prozesse werden einen bewusst wie beim
selbstbewusstsein man sieht sich selbst
und erkennt sich so selbst und so ist es
auch bei der bei der kurs bei der
religion wie man die eigene zeit in
gedanken fasten oder irgendwie zu sich
kommen lassen ja ja ich würde jetzt den
spiegel das ist schon richtig dass es
ganz entscheidend ist dass es immer ein
rücke eine rückkehr ist ein selbst
klimatisierung und reflektion denke aber
dass bei dem der spiegel metapher
vielleicht ein bisschen zu kurz kommt
das ist tatsächlich etwas anderes auch
ist in dem ich mich selbst erkennen
der spiegel ist ja sehr stark so dass es
mich direkt wieder gibt während jetzt
wie wir eben schon mal den anerkennungs
überlegungen gesagt haben ich mich jetzt
erkennen würde gerade in dem ich mich
mit ihnen beschäftige und dann gerade
die andersheit erfahren würde gerade das
wäre ein weg mich selber zu erkennen und
das ist da ist die spiegel mittag
vielleicht nicht glücklich
in einer fremden perspektive hier sehe
habe ich ja also es ist so unmittelbar
der spiegel irgendwie und hege möchte ja
eher eine sehr vermittelte also dass ich
wirklich durch in fremden und durchaus
anderes gehe und so wieder zu mir
zurückkommen also das ist auch wieder
durch dieses sozusagen ins andere gehen
und dann wieder ein anderer werden haben
oder ja und in dem und vor allem auch
indem wir das beide machten machen wir
ja auch was gemeinsam und dadurch
verändern wir dann wiederum auch das
menschsein und die verhältnisse in denen
wir leben das ist ja auch das gar kein
individueller prozess wir beim spiegel
auch er beim spiel ist eine aktiv die
anerkennung das hat da machen wir jetzt
eben nicht so lange darüber geredet die
anderen kinder und ist jetzt tatsächlich
etwas was so wichtig ist dass das
wechselseitig stattfindet also dass ich
nicht nur mich in ihn erkenne sondern
sie sich auch in mir also diese beiden
sachen es müssen von zwei seiten
vollzogen werden oder dann halt noch von
mehr seiten vollzogen werden und dadurch
verändert sich natürlich auch das was
uns zu dem macht was wir sind nämlich
das menschsein und diese prozesse das
sind die die hege durchgehend
interessieren wo wir noch mal zurück zu
kunst und religion so viel genau und
dann würde hält hegel sagen dass man
dass der mensch sich in diesem sinne
auch entwickelt ein bisschen so wie wir
gerade gesagt haben nur jetzt von hegel
wieder sehr aufgeladen das ist
tatsächlich verschiedene phasen gibt in
denen diese formen der
selbstverständigung sich dann auch
entwickeln und modifizieren und immer
komplexer werden und ziemlich banal ist
dass ich mich eher in anschauen da weise
über mich selbst verständige das
passiert in der kunst also kann sie
bildlich in der religion mache ich das
er in vorstellen da weisen das heißt zum
beispiel um meine freiheit zu erkennen
denke ich ein wesen was nur frei ist
dass es gott also es ist jetzt natürlich
eine bestimmte generation aber da hat
dieser hat diese ganze rallye also diese
ganzen religions- philosophischen
aspekte schon klar auch die dass daran
etwas erkannt wird nämlich was freiheit
überhaupt ist und so interessant weil er
war ja ein gegner von schleiermacher der
religion ist ein gefühl der schlecht
wenigen abhängigkeit das pure gegenteil
oder ja ja ja da waren
haben die auch glaube ich beides machen
das sicherheitsbewusstsein das bei regen
in der region lahmgelegt
sogar in der kunst schon genau und und
jetzt in der philosophie da sagt er das
ist nicht mehr vorstellen sondern
denkend in der philosophie soll sich
jetzt wiederum das was in der religion
dann sich vollzogen habe noch mal
verziehen vollziehen nur in der form das
ist jetzt auch denkend erfasst wird das
heißt ich stelle das nicht mehr vor als
ein gott der irgendwas macht sondern ich
durchlaufe eben dieser logischen der
denkprozesse sowie hier gemeint dass er
das in der wissenschaft der logik
gemacht hat und in dem also eine weile
diese thesen hat ist es auch klar dass
sowohl innerhalb der kunst eine gewisse
entwicklung stattfindet also auch
verschiedene kunstformen sind zu
verschiedenen zeiten die
ausschlaggebenden als auch dass es so
eine art von entwicklung von kunst
religion und philosophie gibt
nun könnte man natürlich also und das
sagen auch viele noch immer sagen dass
diese anschauen der form der
selbstverständigung für uns trotzdem
auch noch relevant bleibt auch wenn wir
eben denken gewesen sind und jetzt
irgendwie uns auch in dieser form des
denkens irgendwie in der weise
verständigen können dem muss jetzt hegel
nicht unbedingt widersprechen aber er
hat schon die these dass das uns jetzt
am angemessen und die die uns jetzt am
angemessenes reform der
selbstverständigung die philosophie ist
so dass die philosophie jetzt so in dem
sinne dann mehr zu sagen hätte als die
kunstnacht asse der viele und ich auch
jetzt nicht zustimmen
jetzt sehen wir den ganzen tekel
durchgegangen das ganze system beim
absoluten geist gelandet versuchen wir
doch noch mal so ein schritt zurück zu
gehen und zu sagen was können wir
mitnehmen in unser denken im alltag he
got to go was wären für sie ideen die
heute besonders aktuell sind oder immer
noch aktuell sind die wir irgendwie
ihnen auftakt haben können also ich
finde schon dass diese idee von hegel
dass man sich mit position
auseinandersetzt und aus denen etwas
gewinnen dass die für uns verbindlich
ist also auch heute noch verbindlich ist
und auch zb in zwischenmenschlichen
bereich ich denke dass diese ideen von
ihm zur anerkennung
zudem auch was es für formen von
anerkennung gibt inwiefern wir unsere
mitmenschen brauchen auch um uns selber
zu verstehen oder sogar auch um die
natur zu erkennen dass diese ideen von
hegel alle heute relevant sind und dass
man auch ich denke schon dass man hier
ein stück weit in seiner art so
philosophieren folgen kann
in dem sinne also nicht weil ich hege in
jetzt allen sachen recht geben würde
oder so sondern eher weil dieses
irgendwie die komplexität er nutzen um
zu überlegen wie sachen miteinander
verbunden sind das halte ich schon für
uns eher faszinierenden und auch schon
sehr attraktiven zugnummern kommt
tatsächlich oft vielleicht nicht so
eindeutig zur behauptung die man am ende
unterschreiben will
aber man hat wenn man so über
anerkennung und diese sachen macht denkt
schon das gefühl dass damit eine menge
phänomene erfasst sind die in anderen
philosophischen entwürfen er nicht so
vorkommen oder nicht so ernst wäre ja
denken dass so etwas wie erkenntnis mit
freiheit mit dem guten leben
zusammenhängt und liegen ja auch in
verbindung ist was würden sie denn sagen
sie haben gesagt sie würde nicht alles
unterschreiben
gibt es dinge wobei man sagen muss
regelt das lager ist komplett falsch
da muss man korrigieren also mein
verständnis von philosophie ist
insgesamt jetzt nicht so dass man
jemanden zu stimmen muss damit man ihn
für einen wichtigen philosophen hält und
tatsächlich also über vieles über das
wir so geredet haben bei vielen sachen
wird ich regeln nicht zustimmen ich
meine nägel ist in dem sinne ja ein
fortschritt philosoph ich zum beispiel
nicht aber ich finde dass wir sehen was
uns auch verloren geht oder was wir
behaupten müssten um so ein fortschritt
doch noch behaupten zu können dass man
das in der auseinandersetzung mit hegel
wirklich sehr sehr gut erfahren kann und
besser als mit als bei manchen anderen
philosophen philosophie ist für mich
eher so eine bestimmte form von
abarbeiten annehmen als einfach sachen
von dem zu übernehmen und in dem sinne
würde ich jetzt auch auf jeden fall
sagen das lästige wo man sich gleich ob
arbeiten muss weil sie einfach ja ich
denke schon dass jetzt was er zu frauen
sagt zu lassen sagt das sind alles
sachen wo die man einfach wo man einfach
sich klar distanzieren muss da ist es
auch dann wieder eine interessante
philosophische frage inwiefern das jetzt
sachen sind dir einfach so beiläufig
auch mal geäußert hat oder ob die nicht
zum teil tatsächlich mit
these über die struktur zusammen hängt
also bei den äußeren aber über den
frauen dann kann man sich das ja klar
verdeutlichen erst sagt denkt man so was
er über frauen sagt dass es stimmt halt
einfach nicht und das lässt man dann
halt weg aber wenn man sich so anguckt
dass er die sphäre des rechts von der
sphäre der familie unterscheiden will
und bei dieser sphäre der familie dann
irgendwie er sowas hab mir dass man
vielleicht ganz plakativ sagen müsste so
dass die verschiedenen parteien
bestimmte rollen einnehmen und diese
rolle neben in ergänzung zueinander
stehen müssen dann ist es gar nicht mehr
so leicht zu sagen er hat ein falsches
frauenbild vergessen dass einfach
sondern an seiner theorie genau dann
muss man sich eher überlegen ob also
welche der anderen aussagen man dann
auch noch alle aufgeben muss oder wie
man die modifizieren kann so dass man
sie doch weiter vertreten kann
aber da gibt es natürlich viele sachen
wo ich sagen würde jetzt so im sinne von
könnte ich das nicht doch glauben oder
nicht fallen die einfach so dieser
ethnozentrismus eurozentrismus ist etwas
das man immer wieder liest dass er sich
für andere kulturen also wenig
interessiert oder dass sie zumindest
nicht so weit fortgeschritten sind
billig wie wir hier genau also auf jeden
fall und auch diese diese auffassung von
philosophie ist schon eine sehr
eurozentrischen also was ist eigentlich
philosophie das denke ich kann man heute
auch auf jeden fall nicht mehr sagen
dennoch wir haben gehört dass wir sehr
vieles von hegel übernehmen zu hosten
oder uns an dem reiben sollen ich finde
es ein sehr schönes bild 4 und
herzlichen dank für diese stunde lang
gegen finster
[Musik]